[Applause]
so what's going on with the ufos mark
so basically new york times put out an
article where they were
talking about they were in conjunction
with the pentagon basically being like
the pentagon is slowly going to start
releasing information about ufos
right now there's a couple things that
are happening in it where it's like
some like they came out and said there's
off-earth
vehicles that are made that are not from
or
world vehicles not made on earth right
one of the intelligence guys said that
we don't know what that means but he
says that it looked like that
and so then some people were taken out
of context being like oh it means that
there's off-world vehicles blah blah
blah right
then i guess it could be something they
just made with the [ __ ] rover on mars
or in the space
station or whatever so this is the thing
that marco rubio said he
is the governor of florida but you
should know
yeah i should probably know that he's a
congressman congressman from florida
yeah
but also does the uh is ahead of like
intelligence
for the ufo ship oh really yeah he's
like deep in the
they put an illegal alien on the
intelligence
the illegal alien ironic i don't get it
but
i didn't even think he was that smart
but apparently he's like he's nice with
it yeah apparently and he was saying
that
it could just be regular [ __ ] so that
they've had weird metallic things
fall on american soil before that turned
out to be like russian or chinese
like uh russian or chinese technology so
we don't know exactly what it is no and
they haven't disclosed anything they
haven't put out any pictures they
haven't said like yo we got aliens
but they do have a ufo like alien
like arm of the military that they said
was defunct
but it's still actually but it still is
so like they came out was like yo we
lied about it still funk
it's funkton that's the thing what
happens like every time they get close
to this pedophilia [ __ ]
all of a sudden there's aliens all of a
sudden like any time politicians get
caught up in
trump presidency trying to take
everybody's mind off of
corona and the economy that's what that
might be it that's what he's trying to i
will you know
it is interesting timing why i started
in a row they're about to end the 600
a week unemployment thing yeah so people
are going to be real [ __ ] angry
and that's something you would want to
take headlines you're about to there's
the recession's gonna get real
when [ __ ] lose twenty five
hundred dollars a month um
leo give them something let's take their
minds off of this yeah this is all about
i think that's that's possible i think
is it i mean i had dinner with that guy
bob lazar
yeah you know who's like the guy who
said he worked on the
the the alien spacecraft and he did you
know rogue and all that kind of stuff
and we
went out to dinner well he was having
dinner with rogan rogan asked if i want
to roll
and i believe that he believes he worked
on them
does that make sense do you think he's
crazy no i truly believe
that he believes he worked on alien
spacecraft now he could be
getting tricked by the powers that be if
you will he could be getting tricked by
the government for example
they could find the spacecraft that came
from china or russia or somewhere it
doesn't matter some other country right
and that spacecraft could have
crash-landed on the united states
and it was like a spy spacecraft
whatever the [ __ ] it was who knows what
it is
and they could be like yo figure this
[ __ ] out and he could think that he was
working on
alien spacecraft when in reality it was
some other countries like you were just
saying
right it could be alien spacecraft but i
didn't get the sense
and again who the [ __ ] am i i didn't get
the sense that he was lying
right because he didn't seem to care
enough right he literally was saying he
was like
look if it's gonna be a thing where like
all you're trying to do is like
discredit me and that kind of [ __ ] like
i don't even care to be on the podcast i
don't even want this attention i i don't
care i'm not selling a book or anything
i don't care
but if you want to have a discussion off
of what i said like i'll talk to you
about it
so the fact that he wasn't like
clamoring for credit or clamoring to be
believed
made me go yeah yeah i don't think he's
really made any money in the last 30
years
yeah like i think he's kind of at peace
with people think he's crazy
and the people who believe him are kind
of crazy
yeah and that's a weird place to be in
the people that you think
are normal don't believe you they think
you're crazy and the people you think
are crazy make you feel normal make you
feel normal
so he's like where the [ __ ] should i
live but i don't even think he has a
consumer product like
he doesn't really benefit from the fame
nope he does like nuclear testing and
stuff i don't know what he does for a
living anymore
yeah but i it was just that was the
takeaway from it i said i cannot say if
ufos exist or not
i don't know i do believe this guy
believes he works do you think they
exist
do you think there's alien life sure
maybe
maybe not like sure like i don't think
they
they've come here yet yeah yeah they
exist
somewhere within the timeline of of
history whether they exist
right now at this moment and they exist
close to us or they
or they have the technology that could
get them here
in enough time to continue to survive
that i do not know i think it's very
conceivable they've come here do you
well we're all pretty much on board
saying they probably yeah right probably
at some point
they ha if you believe in random
circumstance they have to right right
and in like
in an ever increasing or ever expanding
universe
you have to at a certain same to think
the universe is so big
we are an infinitesimally small percent
of that universe
and this is where life is the only place
yeah i'm even interested in the theory
that they could be humans from the past
that have gone and formed their own or
like colonies my brain
can't even wrap my mind around it have
you heard that theory before though what
you said my brain quit
it's like okay time travel sure thing no
not even time
travel just evolution ancient ancient
civilizations that were able to get to
space
and then all that [ __ ] got wiped away no
i don't know do you think these knuckle
dragon [ __ ] built a spacecraft
no
like like you don't look at human human
progression as this linear thing
like maybe you don't have like ice ages
pop up and like everything gets wiped
and then
we start all over again type [ __ ] right
right like maybe there was
maybe it wasn't even this planet maybe
it was another planet right right there
were humans or human type people
and they eventually evolved and they
progress to the point where they have
space traveling technology and then they
start traveling and then they go check
out some other [ __ ] and then they die
out they literally could just
die out in the way rhinoceros is dying
out i feel like we say that because we
want to [ __ ] those aliens and it's
easier if they look like humans yeah but
if there's some weird looking ass people
you're like nah there's no sex appeal in
that yo but that's the other thing like
why do they got to be people to walk
around
like yo they don't right like if you
have a planet that's all gas
yeah they could be just as gaseous the
only reason we walk around is because
the earth is [ __ ] hard
yeah if it was just water we'd be
swimming yep you know like
good point i don't know i it's just it's
crazy to think there's nothing out there
but i think what is out there
might be boring to us i think what's
closest
is probably boring yeah i could see it
being like microorganisms yeah like some
[ __ ] insects or some [ __ ] like
yeah which would be sick it'd be dope to
know there's other stuff dude even if it
was a plant
yeah a little [ __ ] space tree cool
it'd be nice to know
that being said are we gonna have some
conversations with aliens
i don't know brad maybe though you think
i think [ __ ] is gonna get so advanced
here
with ai and everything if anything can
figure out if there's artificial in
earth there's life on other planets is
going to be ai
and then that might be the cool thing
about ai is
it it basically accounts for the
limiting thing in space travel which we
have
which is life expectancy right so
the reason why we can't go to [ __ ]
the next galaxy is because it's 25
million light years away or whatever it
is
i don't live light years yeah i can't
live long enough to go that's another
concept i don't even understand what the
[ __ ] is a light year it's the amount of
time
amount of distance it takes for light to
travel in a year
okay yeah so if you go to the speed of
light for a year that's how far you go
but speed light's the fastest [ __ ] ever
yeah and for a whole year that's how
long that is
ai gonna be faster hey i can be pune
but for real dude think about that like
we can't even fathom that speed
so if you can't even go close to that
like what are we going what do we think
fastest
300 yeah i got the electric bike today
they said that [ __ ] goes 50. i was like
yeah
yeah that's fast
yeah it's just gonna be me going
yo how weird is that that we have a
sound barrier
yeah like that imagine the first person
to break the sound barrier like you were
just going mad quick and something you
just heard an explosion
imagine the [ __ ] that must have been in
his pants bro
cause why should there be an explosion
when you break it yeah
i don't get that [ __ ] that used to
happen all the time over florida every
time the spacecraft like the
there was like the kennedy space center
cape canaveral yeah and they sent off
like spaceships all the time and it
would like shake the windows and windows
would break and stuff
really where you lived yeah my my
neighborhood got a little bit but if you
lived in like cape canaveral like they
would have to get special windows
up because like the windows would break
how often we sending [ __ ] up there
it seemed like all the time growing up
it seemed like every other month or some
[ __ ]
really yeah i don't know if it actually
what are we putting up there bro
i don't know i don't know what there is
to see huh
but what do you i mean like would you
guys send supplies
every two weeks every two months but you
need a whole [ __ ]
spaceship to do that dog my girl buys
tampons like every six months
a balloon or something like if if you
just let it go
until it got high enough and then you
had a motor take over
you could not just fixed it a little
more inconspicuous
why you don't need all the shaking the
windows
yeah that's a good point no think about
it that is a good point though think
about it bro
that's what they just make a whole big
deal with all those explosions three two
one
yeah balloons bro yeah you got balloons
no that's exactly
my head balloons bro think about it it's
balloons
dog what about wind yo say again what
about wind
what about it it's gonna take that [ __ ]
somewhere else why don't you just get a
long rope
and you hold it to where it is yeah out
maravac you let the balloon go all the
way up to the space station with the
rope attached yeah and then
you just attach a little zuzu and then
you could just
have it go there yeah a pulley motor
system you want to send some stuff back
down
tied to the rope tie it to the rope hey
here you go check it out
you know those like why don't they do it
right because they're not [ __ ] smart
like us
listen you've never been in the mail
room you've never been in the mail room
of a [ __ ] company where you throw
that [ __ ] in the socket and
how can we don't we don't do that yeah
how can we hey cape canaveral
how come we houston here's the problem
yeah get the [ __ ] cylinder [ __ ] how
does costco have it but you guys don't
have
costco has it target
has it
yo the rope is so lit the one issue with
the rope is planes flying into the rope
oh make it orange make it orange dude
and yo just do it at a christmas lights
real talk
just do it out of christmas lights real
talk
that's it dude what a when we need
electrical wiring what do we do
it's just a [ __ ] wood thing up
electrical if at first i thought oh the
problem was that the space
the space station would go around the
earth you thought and then it would wrap
up the
you it might it might just keep it there
and then it fixes two problems exactly
exactly because guess what
that thing right there yeah it's got
gravity
yep it's spinning with the earth what do
you do when you get in the space and
there's no gravity
come on now yeah that's for that rope
come on now there's gravity
no
listen you are not rotating around the
earth dumb fast
the earth and you are rotating around
the sun
so you're just going to keep that same
rotation around the sun perfect like
that
done yes
the fact that you suddenly hopped off
board makes me think you were taking it
seriously the first time
now you suddenly not be on board
push back no no no stop protecting
yourself you did believe it
[ __ ] stupid idiot
dumbass clearly saying some [ __ ] that's
wrong and then you believed it
i still believe it yeah
i'm [ __ ] pot committed to this [ __ ]
dog
i'm coming up with this idea yeah the
rope might work i think the rope
works look bare minimum this with the
rope
this is what the rope provides bare
minimum
if there's an explosion mark in the
space station
bare minimum they can slide you put on
your thing
and then you slide down it's like the
beanstalk in mario
2. yes i'm gonna ask you this question
though
you know what i'm saying the beanstalk
in mario 2.
now you have to answer this though
because a lot of people i want to answer
the biggest issue with the rope
situation is that it's attached to
potentially like billions of dollars
right
yeah what is how are you going to stop
someone from this climate climbing it
mark that's what that's the question a
lot of people are wondering about
security
putting it in america mexicans can't
even come here to climb it
and they are the best climbers in the
world they are but what if they have a
big pair of scissors and then they cut
it off
okay that is a real place if they have
like scissors that you cut like first
that is opening that that is a
very very very big problem what do i do
if mexicans are climbing
and they have scissors for a grand
opening and they have the squeezer yeah
the grand opening says this would be a
thing dude they're great
and they chop that [ __ ] off and then
that would be that would be a problem
but that's how russia would win
yes but you could also protect it just
like you protect everything else
with security oh interesting
well also you were saying it's a tube so
what if the rope is in a tube
yeah and that time people think about
the fact that russia could fly real high
and then they could sabotage it that's a
french word
okay uh two ropes we could just do two
ropes
you could do a secret rope actually what
i would do
can i be honest with you i would have a
i would have a decoy rope
i'd be like here's our rope what if you
paddle canaveral
you paint the roll black yeah yeah she's
gonna blend in with the rest of outer
space it blends in with outer space
it's camouflage camouflage you don't
even know another french word another
french word we're doing a lot of uh
french stuff here what i would do is i'd
have a fake rope and i'd be like oh this
is the most important robe like this is
where
this is like where all of our [ __ ] goes
down like this is how we get everything
up and down to space i have fake
astronauts up and down that [ __ ] on the
daily
on a daily up and down astronaut right
all the while i put the real rope
in boston
real talk i bet you would climb right
into a guy's [ __ ] up in that room
real talk that could that could trick
russians yeah
y'all have any other questions